[Music]
environmentalist Crystal frame is on a
mission to change the planet one trash
cleanup at a time
the single mom launched the
environmental justice organization
sustain frame after being furloughed
during the pandemic this itself is
actually full her community service
spans across Texas New Orleans and New
York City with free meals Community
refrigerators and trash cleanups during
the Texas freeze of 2022 she helped make
enough chili to serve 1 000 people who
were without power now that is a Drew
gooder we should all aim to be like
Crystal frame
crewcutter an environmentalist Crystal
frame
what makes you you why do you feel it's
important to educate people on the
environment what started it for you I
mean for me I experienced a lot of what
people would call issues that are
affecting the climate I worked in
fashion and in Hospitality I continually
always pull back to this moment where I
happen to be bartending at a bar in
Brooklyn and I had counted 10 glass
bottles that I had thrown in the trash
myself and a lot of these restaurants
don't have the ability to you know
explore recycling because it's very
expensive and you think of mom and pop
retail place even can experience that as
well it's just again another taxing part
of a small business process but you like
go into your community and during one of
the the Texas freeze you went and made
like chili for a thousand people I was
trying to think about how I could help
other people with the assets that I had
so I had actually planned to do a dinner
for sustain that previous week and I
didn't get a chance to and I had
actually connected with the local
restaurant that was doing a lot of food
give backs and I was like all right I
found some care for my daughter and then
I ran in to go help them make a big vat
of chili like it was the thing I they
were like here's five cans of tomato I
need you to blend that up and I was like
okay and we ended up feeding 1200 people
we also took in um some resources that
we were handing out and it was such a
beautiful experience to see such
Community come together we just
experienced such a traumatic moment well
you know it was a lot what you did was
incredible and a place that I've
actually traveled to that I really love
is Costa Rica and I was amazed
by how sustainable and Forward Thinking
everywhere I went was and I just thought
I wish this was more ubiquitous I wish
this was more places everything is Eco
and minded and it just blew my mind and
we've partnered with visit Costa Rica
and in honor of the work that you've
been doing we're sending you on an all
expenses paid trip for two to Costa Rica
and ring forests and waterfalls and
peaches and mineral mineral Rich thermal
Hot Springs it's really an amazing place
where you go and it just seems like the
what the future should look like and how
it should function and
um there's also a really fun fact the
sloth is the national symbol of Costa
Rica and everyone in the audience
actually has a sloth
um is this right everybody has their
sloth okay
does anyone have a sloth with a yellow
heart on it you do
okay well you just want an all-expense
paid trip
[Applause]
what is your name
I'm uh my name is Sarah Luke Sarah Luke
can you get a way to go to Costa Rica of
course yeah
oh my goodness
I have dreamed to go there my whole life
as well and I had never been there until
just a few years ago in 2019 at
Christmas and I loved it so much we
ziplined we went to beaches we surfed we
went into waterfalls and it was so
Soulful it's one of the most beautiful
places I've ever been to on planet Earth
and the opportunities for adventure and
wellness and they say romance and
exploration are unlimited I was on a
vacation with my two daughters but it
really is a special spot on our planet
and it's one of the most visited
International destinations in Central
America so congratulations thank you so
much coming today and I can't thank you
enough for coming and making us aware to
take care of our communities it's such
an honor thank you thank you
[Music]